okay hi everyone so we are having a busy
afternoon of livestream meetings this is
another meeting related to often
language design this is part of our
language completeness and consistency
series talking about a variety of topics
that have come up there we will be in
about an hour doing a meeting about
black holes and physics completely
different subject this is why I have an
interesting life um very diverse
collection of issues so let's jump into
this the at equals operator remind me
what the odd equals operator is supposed
to do it's supposed to be so you do X at
equal map of F and it evaluates
basically to x equals map of f of X okay
so in other words what we're saying is
is this is this running in any versions
no okay
because we haven't picked a name for
this symbol and so we can't create a
full form if we don't have a name
okay so fundamentally it's x @ equals f
and yet equivalent to x equals f of X
yep yeah that's kind of nice how how
certain are you I mean if we put this
into twelve two it'll be interesting to
see if people find that they use it
right that's what this was actually an
external suggestion I forget from who
but I may be Sandra okay I mean I I
wasn't involved in the curation of this
suggestion but I have to say that there
would definitely have been times I would
have used it right because this seems
very sensible to me right because
especially if you know F is not just F
but some
you know composition of operator forms
then all right well actually in my case
I might very well have used it just in
the single case because it helps to kind
of you know prevent the levels of
nesting that make it unreadable you know
if you know if you're applying you know
a series of transformations you can put
them all nested in square brackets and
it becomes very difficult to read or you
can have a series of lines that you know
x @ equals first transformation that
excite equals second transpiration
mm-hmm oh I see what you're saying I see
that's nice right I mean so in other
words you're saying exit equals F X that
equals G that's really pretty nice
actually yeah um good idea okay I think
I really make a difference for
readability and certain kinds of code um
okay it is indeed Sander probably who is
the originator of this good okay so
let's talk precedents here um so clearly
AMPAS and it should be lower precedence
than amperes and we agree so in other
words we should be able to type X at
equals one plus hash ampersand yeah
that's important so so now interestingly
if you look at plus equal minus equals
star equals slash equal those are just
slightly higher than ampersand right
that's one of the things I put in my
dissidents table where is the
president's table you can just search
the help for operator input forms yeah
okay all right well whereas I was you
want to look close to the bottom of that
first table you're still in the first
day it's a long table but okay so yeah
they're good
there you go hold on first first
question is so let's talk about some
above and below ones okay Sandra is
pointing out a precedence stuff in the
red mine issues tracker somebody bring
that up please um gosh I don't even know
my login to this thing I'm afraid um
great could somebody please bring up the
relevant entry I'm looking at 6:35 and
trying to see it's 6:35 yeah yeah I'm
trying to see what what to glean from
here so let's talk about um it should be
should be higher than should be lower
than okay okay so it should be lower
than amperes and for sure it should be
higher than equal sign right because you
go be able to say x equals whatever
right yeah mm-hmm okay so let's let's
see where that buckets us that brackets
us here
okay so there's ampersand lower than
ampersand okay so there's slash slash
here are we already toast is equals
higher than no equals is fourth from the
bottom
or sorry set I'm sorry set is fourth in
the bottom okay so basically we living
in this zone here if we're if we're if
we're lower than Amazon than higher than
equals then we live in this zone here
so the only things that we can that with
slash slash is an important one
okay let's talk about that case so we've
got X at equals F whoops F / / G so I
think it'd be nice to be lower
precedence than slash slash do you agree
I think it really would be nice to be
lower precedence and slash slash lower
precedence so that means that it's
really a question of does the assignment
because this could be either represent
either either could be could return I
mean either way this is return to return
F G of f of X it's always going to
return that the question is what did
it's a sign they did a sign f of X so
that is a sign G of f of X so no that's
that's not true right if it's lower then
it would be F of G applied to X as
opposed to G of F yes sorry G of F
applied to X as opposed to G of f of f
oh that's crazy expensive of F and G are
perhaps no it's crazy because I mean if
it's slash star their composition no no
I'm just simply wrong I mean it has to
be this has to Brent the size like this
it couldn't it couldn't make any sense
otherwise you're just gonna have a bug
yeah right yeah I I tend to agree with
that
which leaves Colin perhaps you were
thinking of writes composition I was yes
but I mean so okay so what where is
write composition in the precedents -
yeah it's way above okay so fine so it's
way above so that's no problem
right right okay okay so um okay so
what's left is :
right and there's there for which i
think is a right and colin is is kind of
ridiculous right i mean it's the thing
that just formats as a : that's not and
at
: on the keyboard what is it I don't
understand what that is and vertical
separator is the same stuff well then I
would think this should be lower
precedence than those so I think this
precedence is right above the precedence
of equals
do you agree right yeah I'm okay with
that
yep okay all right that's okay now let's
talk about names the full full name of
this by the way I would like to comment
and I should say unlike unlike etai I
don't have to wait for a name so I can
yeah III if you want I can just eat I
can just go ahead and implement this
probably today as as an ascii operator
operator yes you'd need the name for the
unicode operator which i presume you
want do we want the unicode operator I'm
not sure it's necessary I mean I'm happy
to discuss it if you want it but it
doesn't seem necessary to me okay okay
let's talk about the naming of operator
forms because I have always been upset
or recently been upset but that does not
have a name in other words I've often
wanted to
you know what why do I need this I want
to I gosh what is the use case I need it
to have a name basically and it's like
you know it's it's it's sort of apply
one well it's exactly right
um okay sander is pointing out the idea
that a single argument version that
converts any function like plus into add
two into an apply and place function
would be neat
okay let's understand what that means so
let's say this thing is called well I
mean I would have thought this was um by
the way it doesn't matter that the name
is short for this thing really really
doesn't matter it might matter more if
there's a pool operator form but um I
mean it's a terrible name but you know
set construct is what it really is what
no actually well construct two or
something isn't it all right isn't the F
I mean something where we say construct
F X that's the name for the applying a
function right great I mean I guess
composed us that - although composed -
deprecated one I can't remember composes
deprecated
right I mean I all right unlike
construct this isn't fard right and
constructive Zafar are great that's the
one that takes F yes and wine creates f
of XY then that should be construct
equal
what do you mean equal because not equal
construct it's not equal
yeah we're talking about that's what
that's the whole topic yes so it should
have equal in the name because plus
equal what are you talking about no plus
equal is AD - there's no we're using
this to construct it is being applied to
something but I'm trying to understand
Sanders suggestion about a single
argument version that turns it into ad -
so let me just understand that so um ad
- takes an X and it takes a DX so to
speak mm-hmm okay so the question then
is is there a a thing that would take
this function okay so a headdress
effectively that will turn plus into ad
- right so this is a two in headdress so
here's what it would be it would be the
UM this is a terrible name but something
like operator - of f of X comma DX and
that would become x equals let's call
this Y here Mia do is find a polymer
fall first
yes and we find other another problem as
well which is that that add to is
expecting two arguments here right this
is in fact I'm confused here this is
let's see x equals it but that's not the
correct add to form the correct add to
form is instead x equals f of X hmm oh
but that's I see if you emitted the X
that would be okay so fine I understand
so there's a that also suggests a
currying mechanism for this thing here
because you can imagine that if i say x
equals f of X yeah yeah yeah look look
look look look look if that was
construct 2 with F X Y Z okay that could
be x equals f of X Y Z could it not be
where basically the y&z are constants
it's all I'm saying mm-hmm
it's strange X to be the first one
if an X are both special right but I
mean I also be lovely if the operator
form of this you know the operator form
of this construct two thing if it was
possible to do it if we could say
construct two of F okay we understand
what that operator form would be I think
mm-hmm and that operator form would but
now I don't even know if the other would
be yes because it can't do hold first
um return a pewter function e and you're
very soft so I can't actually hear
whatever Center and up here function as
a way to deal with the holding right
probably could
let's see Santa is making an interesting
suggestion of a set to function ah well
let's see wait a minute
set by rather yeah s WS H is saying that
they're not a fan of mutable functions
nor am i but mutability is is something
we humans seem to understand well even
though you know at least yeah um okay
but let's look at set by so is this an
alternate name for our constructor or is
this a new function I think this is
related I mean so the suggestion being
made is that set by a square root could
then be applied to wait a minute oh I
see I see so if there's an X there this
would become x equals square root of x
but why isn't that the same as what we
just did isn't that isn't this just what
we've got just got isn't business the X
X ad equals square root yes you know
what am I missing
seems seems right but but and and it and
it doesn't I see I see I see I see I see
the proposal is that it be possible to
get
a function where you could say square
root 2 equals set by square root but the
issue there is that the sub value can't
sub value can't reach in and prevent
evaluation of the X right right how
fundamental just just for my
understanding of you know I mean it's
got 30 something years of history but
how fundamental is the inability of a
sub value to affect its arguments is
that deeply fundamental or is that
something that we can imagine changing
at some point in other words could there
be a I mean it would be basically hold
and still hold first hold rest it would
be hold sub value that would then be the
head of the head of the head determines
what is being evaluated Rob any insight
into that I I mean I'm not sure we again
we have I'm not sure we have the bits
for extra flab forever extra attributes
but even if we did I'm not sure how hard
this would be
they're pretty scarce but forget that
issue because that's another issue that
we have to address separately um but but
I'm just I'm asking the question is it
worth considering the possibility of a
hold sub value and if we did that what
consequences would it have because for
example in this case then what's being
proposed to set by could have an
operator form and the sub value could
work
somebody's got a lot of background noise
there right so I honestly don't know
whether it would even be possible
well maybe we can investigate that but I
mean okay so the proposal here so
Sanders proposed name here of set by is
interesting and not an obviously bad
name right yeah and certainly the two
you know the two argument form it's fine
I mean by XCOM up so so the form would
be it would be that would be it would be
X comma F yep and it would be hold first
and that that seems like a fine
suggestion right I'm when could even I
you know potentially have although this
may be an unnecessary can confusing
luxury would be to have additional
arguments there wisey which would be
essentially put into what where the
answer would then be x equals f of X Y Z
I don't know that anybody cares about
that I think it becomes more interesting
in some operator forms I don't show that
that's worth doing
you could perfectly well just have the F
be a hash thing there let's just think
about set by for a second is that
consistent with our other use of by and
other functions I think so right because
for example if you have sort by right it
applies to function and then uses that
to sort
so here it's applying the function and
then it's using using that to set
whoever's making a lot of background
noise maybe it's Rob could you meet
please um
I mean the rest of the by functions I
sort of think of as being things that
are iterating over a list
I would expect said bye to the X comma y
comma F and it first applies F to the Y
well I mean the more you know set width
would be a more English language thing
but unfortunately with has so many other
connotations for us set after not very
good I'm missing the two because
everything we have which is L value has
this to me but the two is sort of
redundant was set right
no because said always has the left hand
side and the right hand side repeat the
two always implies the left hand side I
know the to add to the two is the thing
that's indicating the mutability part
that the assignment part of it and the
ad is indicating the operation right and
then set said is the thing that's
indicating the mutability right the left
hand that the first argument is going to
be changed
I mean absent and operate a form of this
which will be nice to have but absent
that operator form and by the way I mean
in principle although it's pretty
complicated I mean function if it
returned a pure function function does
have a third argument with attributes
right so you could say function of f of
hash what would you say you would say
function of how does this even work X x
equals f of X hold first doesn't that
work yes
so in principle as I think ian was
indicating set by of F couldn't
principle return that pure function and
it would then work well perhaps by that
time it has also evaluated the other
bracket which other bracket if you say F
or G goes to this function object and
then G of one plus one suspect it would
have evaluated the one plus one before
using the function now heads but heads
evaluate the four arguments no but
that's not the point the point is here
this thing here if I say if I have a
variable X xx equals seven okay and now
I apply this thing to X X X it will give
me a F of 7 and xxx will be F of 7 and
we're good yes but if you called G
equals this function and then apprise G
of xxx I suit you're saying let's check
let's take a look at that I'm not sure
that's gonna work G of that and then say
G GG of xxx right because again heads
evaluate the four arguments so you're
saying that worked yes so it is feasible
by the slight hack of having the
operator form actually evaluate to
appear function we could make this work
right okay so I think we should look at
the operator form seriously then so that
argues ok so I mean Sandra is commenting
that that all of our things times by add
to subtract from there all horrifyingly
different
girl circus is saying that they like set
to I think that's a little obscure I
think set wouldn't set by set after set
using right I mean I guess set by is
like consistent with well no it's the
opposite set right we have divided by is
one of our so in that sense it's sort of
reversing the darts hopelessly reversing
it well okay here's it his a version
that that's kind of crazy because all
the other ones at times
hmm oh why does it always come down to
names um
we've got several candidate names here
we've got set to although I just need to
save this appropriate place ah anybody
know how I'm gonna save this just under
a functional programming even though
this is specifically not a piece of
functional programming sadly um so I'm
wondering whether if we look at a larger
class of functions if it helps with the
naming right like so suppose we also
added map 2 which is basically whatever
the thing is that we haven't named with
the right hand side being you're saying
that this is this would be x equals F
slash at X correct right well I think
then we're back to construct two or
possibly apply to it's not applied but
we have applied sides image apply
various things that are not applying
sorry say that again I see you're saying
that apply has been already abused yes
apply is already a general concept not a
specific one
right so we have apply sides which
applies F to oh you know all sides of an
equation so and by apply we just mean
saying f of X naught F at X correct
image well I mean so then apply to is
the obvious name and the operator form
apply to F
fine I mean but the I mean this is you
know most of the time people will just
type at equals and it will be called at
equals and they need knowledge that at
equals happens to be applied to is some
look apply to is the obvious name unless
we want to call it at equals no we
haven't done that that was that that is
a self referential confusion so just
imagine all the things that were you
know that that that does not even give
people a hope yes map is turned into you
know is name slash at all right I think
we got it apply to I think we should
look at an operator form that evaluates
to this pure function with a hold first
and I think we've got this so out of
curiosity in like add to in the full
form which order are the arguments it's
it's X comma DX okay so the argument so
what you're saying is apply to goes X
comma F right right but what I was
learning is whether you can then say X
comma F comma 1 and get the triple at
version you know through a full form
even if there's not an operator for it
so what are you proposing that that's
apply you're saying you want to have a
level spec I'm throwing it out there as
a possibility I think the level spec has
many different possible things I mean
you might want a map you might want to
apply you might wanna play at level one
I mean I guess you can get all of those
with level specs no you can't one of
them is going to I mean the map versus
the apply is different exactly
so what bread is saying is that if we go
this route we cannot have the two
version of of the drop light yes yeah is
what you're it's an implication of what
you're saying okay that saying X equals
F at at X but you're never going to want
to do that because think about the
syntax this is never going to work
because the only way that would work is
if X is a list oh I guess it could yeah
I'm sorry it could work it's weird we
haven't needed it in 30 years I think we
probably are not gonna need this right I
mean the triple add version could work
we might be interesting but let's go
ahead and implement apply to and get it
all working and play with it
okay okay okay yeah triple layout was
what I was a head in mind okay so this
is sort of if you want the horrifying
business so round trip is totally
horrifying look the point is we didn't
use this for a round so this is purely
decorative this plus equals is a purely
decorative thing right well plus minus
and minus plus I'm sorry Matt plus minus
minus plus yes are they mixable well in
this
I mean nod and not flatly right but you
could I see so do you propose that this
be flattened able like inequalities or
like plus no but oh you oh you mean no
I'm not proposing that I'll voice they
supposed to good I'm proposing that plus
minus itself be flat in the bowl
and and so we well I don't know what
these are useful because these don't
have a you know they don't currently
have an evaluation meaning right well
they're used for for formatting and
people do use them I would find that
dangerous because we have a - there
if we make it flattened it's like making
- flutter but my - is flat as I showed
above
yeah I mean - and plus flatten to one
another okay look first point is we're
not really using + - yeah I mean
actually what what isn't showing above
but is true at least in the front end I
assume is true in the kernel as well is
that a plus B minus C is also flats yes
in a very weird way right and and and
the front end considers it flat there is
no you know associate associativity
there as far as fern is concerned that's
a flat row box right so what would be
involved making plus minus and minus
plus fully mutually flat each I didn't
realize this was your proposal I thought
that you were proposing making it flat
with plus and minus well that's a whole
different thing so that they're mutually
flatten a bowl with plus minus plus
minus and minus plus I think this -
might mean subtract - never means
subtract but in plus minus when you have
Christ - you are meaning you might be
meaning I have either a plus B or
subtract a comma B okay okay let me just
understand something I mean we have
never implemented even
like the quadratic formula with plus
minus right plus minus is purely
decorative right now mm-hmm
we did consider the possibility of
actually having I mean we could
perfectly well have an algebra of plus
minuses we just haven't done it do we
want to do that I mean that was that was
on the table a couple of years ago to do
that I I don't think we want to do that
I just think I mean I I just think we
should make you know these things
round-trip properly because there are
bug reports about this okay I understand
the round tripping is reasonable but I'm
asking the question which i think is a
separate question and nobody in this
meeting is probably quick to answer it
of whether we make plus/minus a you know
we could perfectly well have an algebra
of plus minuses which will be but I
think that's where around us for know
but not the whole point that's that's
what around is a plus minus in the sense
of a see a distribution you know that's
a plus minus and a sense of multiple
choices a see there I think plus minus
is like an interval you know it's it's
like something where it's just another
it's a discrete you know it defines a
discrete set and if you're doing that a
plus minus B plus minus C if you were to
resolve that how many elements does it
have does it have four elements does it
have I mean I think there's an argument
that it should have four elements you
know for all possible signs plus minus
going threading through there mm-hmm
well but these things for example you
may want to have two equations one with
all the signs on the top and another
with all the signs on the bottom and not
all the powers of two right but if you
if you were to nest the plus minuses
then I mean this version here right is
clearly the case of four things is that
not right
yes but what I mean is that if you
flatten it then you might mean that you
have to one with the top science one
with the best so the argument there is
these are in fact this is in fact not a
flat operator hold on hold on hold on no
the fact that you can parenthesize and
well okay so so there's flat in the
sense of the attribute flat but there's
also flat parsing right so if I write if
if plus minus of ABC is to make any
sense then a plus minus B plus minus C
must parse to plus minus of ABC which it
doesn't okay I understand that issue I
understand the deceit but then what do
you think that means if we were to have
plus minus resolve right of this
whatever you know if we would have a
function plus minus resolve well if we
want to give it if we're saying that
that's distinct and that's the one where
they're all plus are all - okay so
you're saying this turns into that turns
into a plus B plus C a minus B minus C 3
whereas this thing here it's just right
now the parse form of this would be the
thing which I think correctly would turn
into um you know whatever it is all the
four cases dot dot so okay so what does
that mean about parsing that means that
the the flattened form of the flattened
Paris should turn into the Virage plus -
yeah and the barrels plus - should be if
we represent it algebraically should be
the upper signs and the lower signs but
not mixing right which i think is
reasonable now I think it's a separate
discussion and I think I think we have
coming up a discussion about elementary
math and our support for additional
elementary our thing
we might bring up this plus minus and
matter for Devon if you can not sure who
is peeling that that's something in the
Roger Empire yes I can check ok um
alright so what's that what are the
other questions here
we're just saying this is this will flat
parse to the very rocks form right and
then I guess the other question is
should we uh you know allow it to auto
flatten with plus and no oh Auto flatten
with plus I will be super careful until
we understand the algebra right because
I don't even know what the you know the
minus of this whole thing I don't know
what that means it will depend on
whether with which of these you know
sets or the upper and lower rails there
are something like that so this is it's
hardly impossible but I'll just point
out that it will be a bit tricky to
implement because we have four things
that have the same precedence two of
them will merge with one another and the
other two will remain separate but
they'll all flatten in some way now I
I'm personally I think this
implementation should be I think we
should not go to a lot of effort here
until we understand more about this
algebra because I think we may yet have
some issues there um whether we have a
couple of comments on the live stream I
wanted to respond to so Sanders pointing
out that X at equals apply of F would
correctly do the application version of
at equals although it wouldn't do the
apply one version although if we named
Triple at apply one it would do that
what do people think about naming Triple
at you know because I think that's a
good case right so let's look at that
case so this case x equals x x at equal
apply F does the obvious thing right
but then the question is what is the
version X at equal apply F 2 hash comma
1 which is the form for F triple or a
graduate different way f at equals F
triple at hash ampersand right which
will take F and put it into the list
elements that are in X I'm not mistaken
am i confused here I'm now that this
will take it so if X is here is equal to
ABC yeah
this will be an F at at a f @ @b f @ @ c
now notice that x @ equals map of f
we'll just do the right thing that'll
work perfectly so the only one that's
kind of awkward is this triple at 1
again feedback on apply 1 I was looking
at which other functions ending 1 yeah
yeah I know that I know that which is
why I was also concerned about that I
mean it you know it could be yeah I top
is the possibility what that first it's
not first completely wrong
so again F triple at let's say you know
ABCD okay does that okay so what how
would we describe that
why enter by first level each that's
interesting it's interesting we need to
rap soon here um play each is
interesting
I kind of like that it's good
well it just evaluate directly to apply
of blah blah blah well he would do the
evaluation it's not gonna don't gonna
turn into apply blah base one and so on
um and this is basically so we can get
an operator for him right yes because
apply each of X of F would be F triple
at um well I'm a I mean I'm a bit
worried here right because if this right
I mean I think you're suggesting that we
actually change what triple at parse two
parses to and that that has oh I'm less
concerned about that I'm more concerned
about providing an operator form if
there's an issue with what it pauses to
right now I wouldn't worry about it too
much because right now the parse is
directly to apply right and which if it
just goes a heads and evaluates right
away it's not a problem but if somebody
is you know actually looking at the
result of you know is doing health
evaluation and checking heads that can
break things
okay you got a few other comments on the
live stream and then we have to wrap
this particular meeting so sander is
asking rather amusingly
if we have ad equals two we also have
equals at I think now that is a thing
which is the pre the the a log of pre
increment okay no um
Jose on live stream is asking in
operator form of apply F at level n
something like the map hat function
oh I see a reply it's asking for an
operator form of apply F hash n can't
you do that with map path and just
giving it a zero yes you can it's just
rather ugly right I mean if apply each
is really just for the operator form
then it could be apply each F comma
level spec you mean if it's a pure
operator form if it doesn't have if
apply each is not doesn't have you're
suggesting that apply each F that's
gonna get really confusing level there
with this being a pure we haven't really
done that a pure subvolume thank you
right we have a go function for example
and end with the word function I think
we should let's look at this let's bring
back to a separate meeting I know that
we should conclude this here the various
suggestions here about X triple at
equals which is exotic let's let's let's
remember those but let's basically let's
get at equals implemented and then let's
kind of see how that feels first alright
I have to switch to a completely
different topic
um and good alright um anything else
right now I think we're out of time here
okay okay thanks all okay so people
paying attention to life students we are
about to stitch to a live stream about
black holes and I just need to reset for
a moment and and I'll be right there
okay so thanks all see y'all soon and
Jose could you join us did you get the
information
oh okay great thanks okay